[Music]
It's God. It's
God. It's God.
Question. All right. So, what do you
think the answer is? Let's go.
Given to Jesus or it can refer to what
the Christians had with them in the
seventh century aka the New Testament.
We have an issue with that. Just give me
a second. But before we go to that, I
want to discuss the truth.
first.
That's fine. So the Quran gives two
different either what was revealed to or
what was what the Jews and the
Christians had them in the seventh
century. So we do a general confirmation
of the New Testament by confirming
generally what is true from them and we
use the Quran as a criterion as it
stated in chapter 133 where it calls the
Quran a clarification over the previous
scriptures. And if we go to of the same
exact verse, same exact chapter, it
specifically mentions that is going to
refer to the Quran correcting correcting
the mistakes in the in the accounts and
affirming the truth account of that. So
that's going to be the Islamic. Okay. So
you're saying the angel is two things.
The angel is what Jesus was preaching
orally. And then the angel is
also captain.
Uh possibly maybe. Um I just don't want
to inter.
No, not not too much.
All right. So, so just for
clarification, so the angel is what
Jesus was preaching orally, right?
Correct. And then what and then the New
Testament that they had in Muhammad's
time in the 70s. Correct. So what we
have is the Injil in a general sense.
Okay. So the majority of what we have in
the New Testament is the gospel is the
uh in a sense where obviously we have to
decipher what is historically accurate
or not. uh when it comes to the uh
militia gospels, Mark obviously being
the earliest, you have no issue of doing
a general confirmation of the parables
of the teachings found in there. Uh but
yeah, so and also obviously going to use
the Quran as a criteria as I mentioned.
Where does the where does the B where
does the Quran say that you use the
Quran to tell what the angel is? Uh
yeah. So if you go to chapter 20 of the
Quran verse
133 use clarification over over the
previous scriptures. All right. Can can
we get that verse out?
You said what? What? You said what verse
is? Oh, my phone's dead.
Yes.
I got some water for
you. Oh, you got it.
Right. A specific word in Arab used.
Yeah. They demanded only to bring us a a
sign from his Lord. Have they not
received received a confirmation? While
the same word can also mean a
clarification of what is in it says
confirmation, right? But if if we just
if we go into the wait what what verse
is this again? Chapter
20 vers
133 of what they have
I know you love me I know I know you
love
mentions the same exact verse exact
chapter if we go to open up right now he
mentions let's go to it
uh one second
all right 2133 right yeah so yet the
Quran contains information about the
about the people of the past that tells
of their events from times long ago and
it agrees with the authentic information
in in the previous books concerning
these matters. The Quran is supervisor
over these books. It verifies what is
correct and explains the mistakes that
were falsely placed in them. So that
specifically mentions how the Quranic
author is aware of biblical details many
times edits biblical such as the account
of Solomon such as the account of Moses
account of Jesus and directly amidst
them which is that the Quran author is
aware of these details. Okay so just to
be clear so it says um it says
uh and they say why not has 2133 right?
Why not has why not um did he bring to
us a sign from his lord has u when has
not come to them has not come to them
evidence of what is in the scriptures of
the former correct so it says that the
that what the Quran is bringing is
evidence in their scriptures yeah but
you're assuming that the word has unable
meaning if why why are you taking it to
be to mean that it's like fixing it when
it doesn't say that because the the the
earliest exegetical work such as
clarifies what is So if you're well I'm
just confused. If you're if if the Quran
doesn't say that I I we could agree that
the Quran doesn't say that it's coming
as a clarification or fixing what is in
the scripture the verse doesn't say that
assuming unocal meaning then yes because
it's vocal there's going to have to be
the case where it has definition and by
the earliest understanding we can match
that meaning. Okay. So if we go to like
for example in 1094 let's talk about
right it says that if you are in doubt
oh Muhammad about what we have revealed
to you then ask those who have been
reading the scripture before you and who
are those who scriptures the people of
the book who the Jews and Christians.
Okay that's wrong. According to our
Ali's executical
works, they clarify that those who read
the scriptures are those rabbis and
Christians who were non-believers who
became Muslims after Once again after
Muhammad in the So they're Jews and
Christians, right? Who are Muslims? It
it doesn't say that they're Musl they're
Jews and Christians, correct? No, no,
you know, of course he converted, right?
Okay. So he's a Muslim. Yeah, but Yeah.
So he was Exactly. So he was a Jew. We
got Christians, right? So it says so
just one second. So the people who've
been reading the scripture before
Muhammad who are they and so these are
Jews and Christians correct? No at the
time of the revelation they were they
were Jews and Christians who converted
to Islam. No it doesn't say
that who converted to Islam
after the verse was on their accounts
before after after they became Muslim.
Why? Because they saw Muhammad in the
scriptures. Okay. Boom. So what's their
source for making making sure Muhammad
was a true prophet? Uh the Old
Testament. Exactly. So it was the Old
Testament that verified Muhammad's
prophethood, right? Correct. Okay. So if
he wasn't in their scriptures, they
could have judged Muhammad as a false
prophet, right? Sure. So then what's the
judge on who on Muhammad's prophethhood?
Is it the Quran or is the previous
scriptures? Yeah. So because the the
statement in 104 is going to be
something known as conditional
possibilities because the condition of
Muhammad as for our narrations is
impossible because the same that's not
no it gives you okay. The narration that
you have states speak a little slower
and clearer for me. Yeah. The narration
that you have specifically mentioned
that Muhammad was never in doubt and he
didn't go ask. That's what we ask. We're
not asking about that. That's not the
argument. Let me land the point. Which
means that 1094 is something known as a
conditional impossibility to convey the
message that Muhammad is in the
scriptures. The reason we know this is
because if I say for example, if I had
wings, I could fly. Obviously, I can't
have wings. So I'm saying it because I'm
conveying the message. But if you had
fly, but it's impossible. So I can't
it's hold on a second. So you when with
your statement you're communicating that
if you had wings you could fly right? So
you're conveying a truth. You're you're
conveying a truth but it's not the
reality of the situation. Right. Yeah.
No it's is the condition itself is
impossible. No no it's not. God can give
you wings. Correct. Couldn't he? Yeah
but obviously. Okay. So it's not it's
not impossible from an altruistic point
of view. Absolutely. Okay. But it's not
impossible. Is Muhammad being possible?
Of course. No. Okay. Oh you can say
that. Let let me let me give you that
it's not possible that Muhammad actually
doubted. Okay. What does Allah tell him
to do if he did? Go toam. No it doesn't.
He does. Can you read Can you read the
verses? Tell me where it says go to
Abdullah. Yeah. So it's it's going to be
a very simple argument. Logic is arguing
that those who are disc
so does the So just to be simple and
let's be honest with you. Does the verse
say if you're in doubt go to Abdullah
Salam? We're not Quranists. I didn't I
didn't say that. It doesn't say that
though. So uh because our clarifies what
is meant in that verse. Do you love your
Do you love the Quran? Not just the
Quran. I love the Quran and the Sunnah.
Do you do you cherish it? No. Logic. No.
But seriously, do do you cherish the
Quran? Do you rever it? Of course. So
you you would I just want cuz I'm I'm on
my point. You would never you would
never add you love the Quran. You
cherish it. You rever it. So you would
never add to it, right? Would you add to
the Quran? Would you ever say something
that the Quran doesn't say? Yes. He
said, "Yes, I got you. I got you." We
derive.
We derive matters from outside the Quran
as well as the Quran. The Quran is not
the only thing that's authorative upon
us. We're not Quranist. Which means that
when we have the Quran and the Sunnah
and the statements of the all three are
going to be binding upon us. You just
want one second. And because Logic is
doing an internal critique,
unfortunately, he's going to have to go
up in a paradigm which includes our
exotical work, which includes our
narration. So now logic because our
exotical work includes these people as
those who read the scriptures because
you're doing an internal critique. You
have to grant it to me unless you don't
want to grant. Well, no. I don't have to
I don't have to grant you your position
cuz your conclusion is wrong. Well, I'm
I'm giving you the Quran, but you don't
like the Quran and this Let me finish
with this. Okay. So you're saying that
according to the interpretation of the
verse that it mentions a narration where
Muhammad goes to uh a former Jew and
asks am I in your scriptures or a former
Christian? Am I in your scriptures?
Right. No. No. No. Oh. So does say oh
really the those who are reading the
scripture before him are specifically uh
Abdullah Salam. Does he say that? Yes.
Oh can you show me that? Of course. He's
talking about the Jew because they have
the sign. They have the sign of Lord in
Deuteronomy 18:18 when God talk to Moses
and he told him the prophecy of prophet
he will send a prophet like you from
among them. So guys so guys pay
attention to the point. No, pay
attention to the point. The the point is
is that he's saying that according to
the verse, those who've been reading the
scripture before you is not talking
about in general the people of the book
as a whole is specifically talking about
Abdullah Salah. No, it's possible.
That's what he said. It's impossible. Is
it possible? So, he's wrong. No, no,
that is wrong. Is that his opinion? He's
antithe why you It's like yes or no.
Because it
is not talking to everybody because the
law of Moses the law of Moses put it
specific for the Jew. Why the Quran
confirm it and suppress the the Bible
with a law to agree. We
agree. So you're on my side and we're
against
him. I don't know why he's specific only
for I don't know either. I don't know. I
just you are right. Thank you. Thank you
so much. Because because the Jew the
time of the prophet they were in Medina
waiting for the coming of the new
prophet and this is what it is. And the
prophet when he come the Jew they were
the first one who turned against him.
This is why he expel them after they
died. I don't know why he's saying that.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
[Applause]
Y out here cooking, man.
You can pull it up, too, but I'll have
the milk. Where's the teddy?
Yeah, sure. Uh,
yeah. sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
You got to translate as you go. That's
fine.
1094 ask those who read the scriptures
before
you from the people of
the Abdah. Ah wait, pause there. So like
Abdullah, what's his name? Abdam. Can I
just call him? Abdah bin Salam. Thank
you guys. So like Abdullah Salam. So
he's just an example of what this looks
like. So he's talking in general. Ask
those who've been reading the scripture
before you and like he did with Abdullah
Ib Salam. Yeah. Because he recognized
the Prophet Muhammad. I got you. So he's
an example of this coming into fruition.
So he fits the criteria. I get you. But
so the point is is that the verse is
referring to the people of the book in
general. Abdullahbin Salam is an example
of this happen. Why is he an example of
it? because it happened in real time.
He's an example because he matches that
criteria of those that can be referred
to find because he was the why because
he was the people of the book. Yes.
Not every person of the people will
recognize Muhammad. However, only those
who reverted will recognize Muhammad. I
got you. But you're not you're missing
my point. My point is is that the reason
why Abdullah bin Salam matches the
criteria of someone he can go ask is
because he's of the people of the book.
I'm not going to that is the only
criteria. I'm saying there's another
qualify
on qualify. They have to be recognized.
Okay. Where do you
get what he's saying? What he's
[Applause]
saying the prophet criteria. Who is the
prophet of God? I got you. So, can you
say it's reasonable that um it's it's
referring to the people of the book in
general and the people who took this
seriously, they would end up believing
Muhammad's a prophet, right? Yes. Okay.
So, it's referring to the people of the
book in general. And when the people of
the book in general check their
scriptures, their scriptures affirm and
verify Muhammad's a prophet. Okay. If
the scriptures doesn't affirm that
Muhammad's a prophet, they can judge
that Muhammad's a false prophet. Right.
Sure. So, what's the judge on Muhammad's
prophethood? Is it the Quran or the
previous scriptures? It depends on who
you're speaking to.
Yo, yo, you got to learn, right? If
you're referring to someone who's uh the
only bind the scripture upon them is
going to be the biblical narrative, then
sure, we can show that. However,
generally speaking, we can affirm
Muhammad's prophethhood without needing
to appeal to the Bible. We don't need to
appeal to the Bible. I didn't ask that.
I I I know that you have your ways of uh
that you believe in Muhammad outside the
Bible. But specifically, the Quran
points to the Bible as a proof for
Muhammad's prophet. So,
of course it does. So, so why is
everybody jumping in? He's doing good,
guys. This guy, this brother's doing
good. All right. He's in election. You
can jump in, man. So, so with this, so
with this being said, right when it
says, go to the people of the book, read
the scripture before you if you are in
doubt, right? So, basically, the
verifier of the of the of Mah's
prophethood and the Quran is the Old
Test is the old scriptures. So that
means that it's the old scriptures
that's the judge on whether the Quran is
true or not, right? Uh yes. Judge if
Muhammad is a true prophet according to
the Jews and Christians. No, not
according to Jews and Christians. The
Bible scripture. All right. We'll do
this again. It says, "If you're in doubt
about that which we have revealed to
you, which is the Quran, right?" Okay.
If you're in doubt about the Quran, then
go check the scriptures. Sure. Right. So
if Muhammad goes and checks the
scriptures, he and he sees that he lines
up with it, he'll he'll know that the
Quran is good and he has no reason to
doubt. Right. Sure. But it's impossible
for him to be down the first. No
worries. Just going with the
hypothe. It's not my Allah gave this
hypothetical, not me. Sure. All right.
So, I'm going with what Allah gave us.
Okay. So, Allah gave him us a
hypothetical. If Muhammad's in doubt, go
check the previous scriptures. So,
Muhammad can go check the previous
scriptures, find himself in there,
correct, and he'll know that he has no
reason to doubt the Quran. Right.
That's true. But yes. Okay. Now if if
Muhammad goes to the previous scriptures
and finds out he's not in line with them
then he'll know that the Quran is false
and he has good reason to doubt the
Quran. Right. Sure. Sure. Okay. So then
therefore the judge of truth according
to this scenario is it the Quran or is
it the previous scripture? The prophetic
message is in the Bible. So whatever
prophesied about Muhammad if it's there
then yes. Okay. So if it's there then
it's good then the Quran's good. If it's
not there the Quran's false. So it's the
Bible that's the that's the judge over
the Quran. Right. Yeah. So if not if if
the if the Bible doesn't pro Muhammad,
Islam is false. Good. So then the judge
is the Bible in the sense that the
prophetic not the entire Bible.
Let me I'm not granting that because the
prophetic the prophetic material is in
the Bible that this must mean that we
must holistically confirm the
scriptures. I'm saying that we
specifically appeal to the prophetic
elements found in the biblical
scriptures. Okay? Not everything. Okay.
All right. No worries. Okay. So this is
what I need you to do. Okay. So we we
agreed that according to Muhammad's
prophet prophethood, right, that it's
the Bible that's the judge on whether
Muhammad's a true or false prophet. It's
not the
Quran. Listen
listen listen the prophet there's no
doubt he is a prophet what I'm saying
the sign the sign is for the Jew and the
Christian to look at their scripture and
to look for him
okay okay sorry
prophet Muhammad he is the true prophet
and the last prophet of of God. And he
knows that while the Christian and the
Jew who they need to do their scripture
and she and see if the sign of the
prophet are found the religion and I
have for you lot of references
references and the
[Applause]
Bible. Okay. So when it come when it
comes to Muhammad and his prophethhood,
the judge is the Bible. He's going back
to the pre older scriptures. So and you
said specifically about Muhammad being
mentioned in there, correct? If he's not
mentioned in there, it's false. So what
I would want is an example of Jesus
mentioning Muhammad. Uh is Jesus the
only part of the biblical of the in the
New Testament? Can we not go to Old
Testament? Well, I'm I'm cuz Well,
because your Quran says that Jesus
mentions him by name. Does it
scriptures? Well, it says, well, where
else would Jesus be mentioned in that?
Wait, wait. No, no, you're not getting
it. He mentioned that Jesus said Ahmed
will come. I agree with that. Wait. Does
it say that Ahmed will come and that's
written in the scriptures? It doesn't
say that. Okay, good. Wait, wait. So,
where where would it be? What we're
going to do is that we're going to go to
the scriptures. We're going to be
scriptures. We're going to go to it and
we're going to go to the Old Testament.
How about Wait, no. The New Testament.
Let me tell you what. I'll tell you
what. I'll tell you what. I just told
you what. John 16. John 16. Let him do
it. John 16:16.
So look, so look, this is where we're
at. Okay. The re the reason why is
because one, it does mention both Old
and New Testament, right? And it but it
specifically mentions Jesus as well,
right? It does. So I'm interested in
where Jesus mentions this. Now, here's
here's let me work this out with you.
When you say that, does it say that
Jesus said it and it's in the
scriptures? You're right. It doesn't say
that. That's fun. Now, where would Jesus
be revealing this? Would this be in
scripture or would this be in like a
hadith of Jesus or something? What do
you mean? When Jesus gives a revelation
that a prophet's coming after him, where
would it be? Um, that's what you're
assuming that everything that Jesus must
have spoke must be recorded and and told
in the scriptures. Well, okay. When So
you you said that when Jesus came, he's
preaching the NGO, correct? So if he's
mentioning a revelation, wouldn't you
agree that a the like a a prophecy of
another prophet is a revelation from
God? Yeah, sure. Okay. So if when Jesus
is given revelation, this is in the
scripture. Would you agree?
No. One second. It's a
non it would be to say that everything a
prophet must have spoke, must be
recorded in the scriptures is a nonsear.
It doesn't follow. No, why not? So you
must justify why is it that No, I'm
asking you where would it be? That would
have to go on there must be in the
scriptures. So where would it be? Logic.
Your argument hinges upon that
everything that Jesus must have
prophesied about every every prophetic
element must be written in the
scriptures. I'm not granting that. I'm
saying I'm saying that it's a facious
argument from silence because we
wouldn't expect it to be evidence for us
to find Jesus and everything he
prophesied about written in scriptures.
I got you. Let me tell you why it's not
an argument from silence. The reason why
it's not an argument from silence is
because we have evidence of the
contrary. And I'm going by the Quran
standard. The Quran says Jesus came
preaching the NGO. Sure. Right. And you
agree that whenever he's giving
revelation, it's in his which is the
scripture of Allah. I haven't even said
that the be the equal definition. What
was Jesus preaching? That must have been
written down. I didn't grant you that.
But you said you said the angel is what
Jesus was preaching and then also the
New Testament that the Christians had an
echovocal definition because it's going
to have a different definition depending
on the context logic. I once again I
never granted you that whatever Jesus
was preaching was actively being
recorded out. I never granted you that.
So what okay so this new test I'm just
confused now. So when you say that the
angel is the new testament when you say
that the angel is the new testament that
the Christians have is so is that is
that the revelation of Allah? Yeah. Uh
guys
let he need some is that is the new
testament that they have with them that
Allah is appealing to you. Is that
revelation of Allah? It wouldn't be
exact. It would be correct in meaning or
it wouldn't be the exact revelation
again. What does that mean? Exactly. If
you if you asked me first before we
spoke what does what do you mean by
provoke I would have explained it to
you. Not issue I got you. When I say
that is going to be guys guys come on
guys come on. When I say that the
definition of Egypt is going to be end
to war. I'm going to repeat it one more
time. It's either going to be refer to
what was originally given to Jesus as
revelation or what the Jews and the
Christians had with them in the second
second century. I'm sorry.
Say Ignoreg. Ignore it.
Ignore it. Ignore it guys. Ignore it.
Ignore it. Ignore. Just ignore. They get
no energy. Do you want to? No. Yeah.
Don't log if you are fake. God
lo so the Egyptians going to either
refer to the what Jesus originally spoke
or the new testament that they had at
now when I say this is you understanding
the head. The testament must be the
revelation. That's what the angel is.
So it's part of the angel not a
revelation. Again, you're equivocating.
You're collapsing the definition. Can
you I'm just Look, can you can you like
justify this in the Quran that they in
jail in some sense is not a revelation.
Yeah, because what it refers to the Jews
and Christians having the injured with
them even though it had but it says but
it says the Quran's confirming that in a
general sense. It doesn't say in a
general sense. Okay, good. Then the
scripture chapter
2. Yeah. Yeah. You got to let him do it.
It confirm what's the truth and the
Bible and then what is because it's
mixed. Your Bible is mixed is be temped
with. Okay. Okay. Good. So God lo asked
me where do you get it from in the Quran
that the confirmation given is a general
confirmation not absolute. Good
question. I agree with this guy's got
this guy. I agree with logic that if we
only take the verses which confirm the
scriptures that we wouldn't be able to
derive a general confirmation. But
because we must take his account
holistically, we reconcile the verses
which affirm the and the scriptures and
we reconcile with other verses and
narrations which confirm the corruption.
Therefore, we derive that there must be
a general confirmation. I see through
reconciliation scriptures. I see. So
you're man that's tough cuz that'll
that'll lead us to does the Quran
confirm the Bible? And you kind of
you're saying yes and no at the same
time. Do the Bible. Okay. So this is
what I want. So, so since it says it's,
you know, Muhammad is in the jail and
the Torah but and the Torah, right? But
in the jail that you're talking about
the New Testament. Okay. So, I want to
see Muhammad mentioned in the New
Testament or his description. Yeah. So,
I can give you an example.
He has Matthew 21:43 specifically
mentions Jesus speaking to the Jews and
saying that the kingdom of God will be
taken away, given to people without
bearings. The question to you is do you
agree that it is the same kingdom took
Daniel 2? No, no, no, no, no. So uh
there's a different context here. Daniel
2 and Matthew 21. Daniel uh in Matthew
21 Jesus says that he's going to give it
he's talking to uh the Pharisees, right?
The ones who disbelieving in him. And he
says he's going to give it to the people
who are bearing the fruit. In Luke,
Jesus says that he's given the kingdom
to his disciples. Okay. Okay, that's
fine. If I'm not I'm not granting I'm
not grant specifically the holistic of
the
the same thing. Just give me a second
otherwise we're going to have a
contradiction but that's why I answer my
question. I just did it. Is the kingdom
that Jesus speaking about that will be
given to the people the same kingdom
that Daniel prophesied about. Yes or no?
Sure. Okay. Good. The same kingdom. So
now all I have to do is prove that the
kingdom in Daniel is the Islamic kingdom
and therefore be no no because you
messed up here because right in Matthew
21 you have Jesus talking about he's
given the kingdom to another to to
others which he specifically says is his
disciples. Right. No worries. Okay. So
do you so I'm not granting a uniform
understanding. You don't have to grant
me No. You said that Muhammad is in the
New Testament. That's what you said.
Correct. You went to a parable where
Jesus is talking about giving the
kingdom to his disciples. Okay. Yes. Now
you just agree with me that that kingdom
is the same fifth kingdom in Daniel. You
agree to that? Correct? Yes. Okay, good.
So now if we show that the fifth kingdom
in Daniel cannot be the kingdom of
Jesus, then it it cannot be the kingdom
given to the disciples, it must mean
that either that the the New Testament
accounts are wrong. Would you agree? If
it is if it's granted that Daniel is not
or or it's a different type of kingdom,
right? So what happened? No. What what
I'm saying is is that if you're if
you're saying that oh um all I have to
do is prove that Daniel 2 is the same
kingdom. If if it's not, then what? We
just have two different kingdoms that
we're talking about. If it's not, then I
can't be wrong. No, it just means that
there's two different kingdoms. That's
not that's not contradicting. I'm not
saying that. I'm just
saying. Listen to what I'm saying.
Listen what I'm saying. Okay. If you're
if you're demonstrating that, oh, if
Daniel 2 is not the same kingdom as
Matthew 21, then that you just have two
different kingdoms. That's not a cont. I
know what that's not what you're saying.
You're saying that it's the same
kingdom, right? You're saying that
Daniel 2 is the same kingdom being
spoken out in Matthew 21. Correct. But
unfortunately for your position, the
kingdom in Matthew 21 is given to the
disciples of Jesus. No, you're you're
assuming that the account in Luke and
the account in Matthew are in
conformity. They're talking about the
same kingdom. Okay. I'm not granting
that in You don't have to I'm saying I'm
saying you the writers of New Testament
shoehorned Jesus into the Matthew and
Daniel. But hold on a second. If you're
if you appeal to Matthew 21 that talks
about the son of God, that talks about
the kingdom being given to the disciples
and then try to uh uh uh put that with
Daniel 2. I'll make it very simple. And
then and then to say, oh wait, oh
actually it's not really the same. I'll
make it very simple. For X, if any X, if
the kingdom of God in Daniel uh uh in
Daniel 2 is the Islamic kingdom, would
you agree that the kingdom talked about
in Matthew? Listen the question very
carefully. for any X if X if the kingdom
in Daniel is the Islamic kingdom would
you agree that the kingdom in in Matthew
21 must also be the Islamic kingdom is a
conditional Islamic that's a question oh
sure sure okay good I agree that Matthew
21 the kingdom of God is Daniel 2 and
good so now me and Logic both agree that
for any X if X if the kingdom in Daniel
is the Islamic kingdom it must follow
that the kingdom in Matthew is the
Islamic kingdom yeah good so so do you
all also agree that since Matthew 21 and
Daniel 2 as the same kingdom. Matthew 21
talks about the kingdom that is given to
the disciples. Right? I I I'm not going
to go into your So, but you but you just
said I'm not going to count. But notice
what you can do. One step. So now So
notice what you have to do. What you
have to do to try to formulate Islam and
shoehorn Islam in there is you No, you
do. You have to go to the New Testament.
You got to pick out. Okay. You know
what? This detail can somehow match
Islam. But when I when we get the full
details of what it's talking about, I
don't like that one cuz that eliminates
this one. So let me eliminate that. You
know why I don't have to do that? The
reason why I don't have to do that crazy
is because logic just conceded that if
the kingdom in Daniel is Islam, the
kingdom in Matthew must also be Islam
whether he likes it or not. So now the
only conclusion that the king if the
kingdom is Islam, the only conclusion we
come to is that the biblical accounts
are wrong. How? Because no because it
would mean that they're not conformity.
So no, that doesn't No, dude. Oh my
goodness. You're missing it. You're
missing it again. Your claim is that the
kingdom in Matthew 21 is an Islamic
kingdom, right?
Uh, no. No. Daniel. Yeah. Matthew 1 and
Daniel. Matthew. Okay. So, Matthew 21 is
the kingdom of God, which is an Islamic
kingdom. That's your claim. Yes. Which
is also referenced in Daniel 2. Correct.
And Daniel 7. Right. Correct. Okay. So,
in all of this references, Can No, we're
right. We're right here. We have to go
to this is stuck here cuz because the
why go to because we're stuck in in what
you quoted. You quoted Matthew 21.
Correct. So in Matthew 21 it talks about
the kingdom that is given to the
disciples of Jesus. Okay. Okay. Is the
Islamic kingdom given to the disciples?
Uh no. Then it's done. It's over. Okay.
It's only over if you assume that the
accounts are uniformity. No. It's only
it's only over if we use the whole New
Testament. Once again I am not granting
If Logic wants to go, if Logic wants to
go to But I don't I don't I don't know
if he wants to. I don't know if you want
to, man. Why Why won't you go to Daniel?
You're in Matthew 21, bro. Okay, but you
just agree with me that the kingdom in
Daniel is the same as the Yes. So, if
it's the same, you have to affirm that
Islam was given by to the disciples. Oh,
that your accounts are contradictory.
No, it's not. You're wrong. What the
heck, my guy? I'm not granted the New
Testament is in conformity. I want But
you're quoting the New Testament. I'm
not granted that Mark, Matthew, Luke,
and John have the same christologology.
I don't I don't Mark the same. So this
is what you need to do. What you need to
do is demonstrate that the kingdom that
Jesus talks about that he's given to
another people when he says the same
thing and he says he's given the kingdom
to his disciples that is not the same
thing. Demonstrate that. Okay, good. All
I have to do is that Daniel is Islam.
No, you don't. No, you don't. Let's go
to Daniel. You have to go. No, you're
running from this. No, I'm exactly on
topic. I'm saying that Daniel is Islam.
Listen to Listen to the problem that you
have. You said I'm not granting that the
Gospels are in conformity. Correct.
You're saying that they're in
contradiction to each other. Correct.
Okay. What you need to do is prove it.
Good. So, I have to substantiate my
pause. Pause. Demonstrate that the
kingdom that Jesus says that he's given
to others and that when he says he's
given it to his disciples is not the
same thing. Okay, good. I'm going to I'm
going to what I'm going to do is I'm
going to put in the syllogism so maybe
logic can actually get it. P1, the
kingdom in in the book of Daniel is the
same as the one in Matthew. P2, the
kingdom in Daniel granted is going to be
Islam. P3 conclusion the kingdom in
Matthew must also be Islam. Which
premise do you disagree with logic? I
disagree with all of it. No, no. Which
premise? Exactly. All of them. Okay.
Wait. Wait. I agree that the kingdom I
disagree that the kingdom is is islamic
kingdom. That's what I disagree with.
Okay. So, can I go to that? No. You
That's You're very slick. You tried it.
You tried it. You're not slick. I gave
you aism. No. And and and let me let me
reverse it to you. You said we have to
answer I am dealing with you and you're
not dealing you're not dealing with me,
guys. You're not dealing with me. Can we
go to the book of Daniel? Did I let you
speak? Scripture. Did I let you speak?
You did, didn't I? Go ahead. Okay. Thank
you. I appreciate it. So, what you're
trying to run away from, you quoted
Matthew 21, not me. Okay. I didn't go
here. You went here. And then I also
gave you an ex an exogetical answer of
what the kingdom is based on the New
Testament. Correct. Who he's given it
to? To the disciples. I don't respond.
You said, "Well, I don't have to take
them as as as uh together in
performance." Confirmity. I don't have
to take them together. Correct. You're I
think that they're disagreeing. Correct.
So what I said you have to do is prove
it. So show me that the kingdom that
Jesus is handing Wait. Show me that the
kingdom that Jesus is handing to others
is not the same kingdom that he's given
to the disciples in the New Testament.
Show me in the New Testament that it's
the difference. Okay. Hold on. Why am I
being constricted to the New Testament?
Because you said it's different. You
came here and said it's different. Okay.
You ask my question. Why am I being
constricted to the New Testament? I'll
say it. I'll say it again. Logic. Why
only I'll say it again. I'll say it
again. Okay. Because you quoted Matthew.
Hold on, please. You quoted Matthew 21.
Because you came to the New Testament
and we g and the answer is in the New
Testament. You're saying that this is
not the same thing. Okay. But you have
to prove it. To substantiate that
premise. Why am I only being restricted
to the New Testament framework? Why?
Because you quoted the New Testament
framework. No, no, I understand quoted
it. But why only the New Testament? You
go here. You bros here. I know, but why
is he only Christian New Testament? Why
can't I use the Old and the New? Why?
Guys, does it make sense that if he
quotes the New Testament, he's bound by
the New Testament? No, I'm bound by the
Bible. I'm bound by the framework of the
Bible. So, if you say that when I ask
you, show me that Muhammad is in the New
Testament. Correct. You didn't quote the
New Testament. I'm going to one second.
Is Daniel New Testament? Old Testament.
Okay. Is it is he hold on a second? Of
course. But if you quote the New
Testament and then you say this kingdom
is the same kingdom of Daniel. Fine. But
according to the New Testament, this
kingdom is given to the disciples,
right? According to Correct. Okay. So
according to the New Testament, it can't
possibly be Islamic because your
accounts are contradictory. Is that
correct? If we only here, okay, I'll
make it very clear so we don't
understand. If logic only grants me the
New Testament framework, I agree. But
unfortunately, this conversation isn't
only bound by the New Testament logic.
You must deal with me and actually go to
Daniel. You have to. Okay. I think that
you have to deal with me and get to New
Jest. Logic. Appreciate it, man. It was
good speaking to you. Yeah, good talk,
man. Thanks for having me. Thank you,
Matthew.
So, where we're at, guys, is that I
asked the brother, "Show me that
Muhammad is in the New Testament."
Here's why we went there. Because he
acknowledged that it's the old
scriptures that are the judge on whether
or not Muhammad is a true prophet or a
false prophet. We got that admission. So
now we understand the Quran is not the
criterion over the previous scriptures.
We got it from the Muslim that it's the
Bible that's the criterion over the
Quran and Muhammad. So now show me in in
the New in the New Testament where
Muhammad is mentioned. He went to the
New Testament went to Matthew 21 and
said this is the same kingdom in Daniel.
We agree. But Jesus says that he gives
this kingdom to his disciples and he
agreed. Okay. according to the New
Testament framework, then I don't have
an argument. It's not about Islam. But I
think that the the kingdom in Daniel is
about Islam. However, this is the point.
If the kingdom of Daniel is the same as
Matthew 21 and he agreed that Matthew 21
is given to his disciples, it can't be
about Islam. It's over. That's right.
Nice try. Islam is false. Hey, thanks
for coming. Appreciate it. We'll see you
on the next conversation.
It's God.
[Music]